[Music]
let's go to los angeles california the
city of angels teresa is on the line
theresa how can we help
hi ken how are you i'm living the dream
teresa what are you doing
so i
i used your principles and i went from
having no job to having a job serving
and in the four months that i did my
work environment was so toxic
i put in my notice so my general manager
finds out and says don't go
let's put you somewhere else let's find
a place for you you're a great worker
don't go okay so he puts me in the
office of the restaurant instead i'm on
the back end of things
so
it's i'm really happy and excited and my
first day was a few weeks ago and i work
with my direct supervisor and she's very
unhappy with me
she's upset and said i was a red flag
because i quit and i couldn't hack it
and
what do i need to do
to
and so and in this time frame it's been
a few weeks now
i'm not really doing much she already
won't mentor me and won't to train me
to help really an assist her and i know
i could do it but she doesn't
like me again and said i was a red flag
and i want to know how i can
get her not to i guess like me but i
guess trust me or
okay i don't know all right so so here's
what i need to know you were placed in
this position by somebody that i'm if
i'm understanding the situation properly
the outranks her correct
yes yes who is that person is that the
general manager the overall like explain
to me that relationship
he's the general manager and she's like
one or two down from him all right and
so he put you there
because he didn't want you to leave the
company he really values you correct
correct does he know about how you're
being treated
no i don't want to say
i almost talked to him but i i don't
want to do that again because i feel
like i need to like earn my street cred
with her not true
she's not
yeah let me tell you why
she's not giving you the opportunity to
earn anything from day one it sounds
like to me you can tell me if i'm wrong
but it sounds like to me from day one
she looked at you as somebody she had to
deal with and that's why she was calling
you the red flag because you quit your
other position you can't hack it she
just doesn't like you for a variety of
reasons but it's all on her side if
she's treating you that like that way
from day one it's not like you did
anything wrong am i right or am i wrong
no you're right there was always
something like we get along but i always
thought there was a wallop with me i
don't know
i mean she's a lot younger than me too
so i don't know yeah yes is she newer
no she's been there eight years does she
see you as a threat
maybe maybe
because i did say like look i don't want
your job i just want to help i want to
do this and when i did say that it got
better well you know what's interesting
you said you i'm a little confused i
need you to clarify this you said you
get along with her
but it didn't sound like well that's not
what i heard in the first two minutes
i get along with anyone if someone gets
along with me it means they like me and
i like them yeah but in this case
theresa gets along with anybody so
meaning you managed to make it
livable yes yeah yes like you all don't
get a little terrible
yeah yeah i guess yeah it's like awkward
silences i guess which i hate but yeah
okay so here's the deal you called me
and you said ken george what do i do
all right okay and i'm gonna tell you
you either be a big girl
and go talk to this general manager who
values you and put you in this situation
to win and you go here's what's going on
i'm just letting you know i'm not trying
to gripe
you put me here you talked me into stain
she's not even using me and it was from
day one there's something there and i
need you to help me navigate it
or this just isn't a fit
you have nothing to lose you were
already on your way out the door once
what are you worried about
you either do that or you just go ahead
and say you know what this isn't the
place for me
because absent of leadership
this gal is not going to change that's
what i know
okay
you agree or disagree okay what's your
gut no i
well
she is leaving for a promotion in like a
few in seven months so that's why i
thought like if i just stick it out and
maybe towards the end she would
see that i stayed well you didn't tell
me that
so here's the deal no no i'm glad i'm
not having fun with you here's the deal
can you stick it out can you put up with
this relationship let's call it what it
is it's a work relationship can you put
up with it the way it is right now and
you're basically sitting around
twiddling your thumbs not because of you
but because of her can you put up with
that for seven
more
months
yes
all right then what do you want to do
i want to prove myself and i want to
move up i want to move up in the company
i'm excited and so proud of myself that
i went from just in four months i'm like
this momentum i have and like i want to
show that i can do it that i could be
a great assistant and help and i
appreciate that
but you are telling me that she's not
allowing you to assist or help that's
what you told me
yes yeah i was hoping you'd say like do
this and then this will well somebody
well we don't do that we don't just tell
you in a situation i know george can
tell you what to do with the baby steps
and money but in a situation like this
i could tell you what i would do and i
already told you that i would sit down
with the gm and go
this is okay unsustainable
okay that's what i would do i would talk
with the gm
um and say well you know what i take
that back george knows this about me
first thing i do i sit down with this
girl and go what's going on have an
honest conversation have an honest
conversation that doesn't put her on the
defensive
it just says look here's what i'm
feeling do you feel comfortable to have
that conversation with her and say hey
listen i enjoy working with you we're a
team i want us to both win and i feel
like there's like this weird tension am
i wrong and just see what she says yeah
okay yes i do i feel comfortable
absolutely let's start with her if she
can't have that conversation then you go
all right well hey i'm going up let's
let's go meet with our general manager i
just want to sort this out so we can be
productive so that we can get the job
done and if you don't want to do those
two things
you can stick it out i don't think it's
going to be great for your mental and
emotional wellness to be completely
honest with you but i also think you
could do it i think you can bite the
stick for seven months she clears out um
i don't know if that's going to open up
the opportunity for you to step into her
role or not but again
you do what your heart's telling you to
do here and you know i admire your
willingness to stick it out for seven
months i don't know that i'd do that but
if i felt like that was the best
opportunity you can guarantee i would do
that george yeah